SCP-096 Vs the M134 Minigun, the world’s
fastest machine gun: Who would win?
The M134 Minigun is a truly terrifying
piece of tech, capable of firing around
six thousand 7.62 mm rounds per minute, often
eliminating even the hardiest of targets.
But what about SCP-096?
Well, as we have learned from some of the
other mind-blowing videos on our channel,
if there is a way to defeat The Shy Guy,
conventional arms fire certainly isn’t it.
The SCP Foundation has fought 096 with
heavy machine guns on a number of occasions,
and on some of these, the bullets
didn’t even slow the monster down.
If you see this beast’s face, we’re sorry to say
that even the M134 Minigun will not save you.
Go watch our 096 videos now and see for yourself!